Interpol shop of flight
um interpol on my case
um
tracked all my flights they knew what I
was doing and yes it's the biggest
pharmaceutical bust in Spanish history
and still is
quarter of a million pills and 50 000
ammules and that's just you yeah right
okay so what happens next
[Music]
thank you
yeah obviously I know you but for people
who are watching this or listening for
the first time could you just tell me
who you are who I am uh
uh drug Smuggler International got
caught with the biggest seizure Spanish
history pharmaceutical drugs Class A
uh
and then after that
we controlled areas
Newcastle North East I've done 11 years
in jail
um
and apart from that after this I've been
all good yeah
what we're going to do now is I'm going
to just go back to where it all started
with you if that's all right go on I'm
just gonna
ask you straight up what was your
childhood like
childhood was [ __ ] uh born 1968
and
it was a ruffle do racism yeah was like
high then yeah okay the conservatives
then 1969 they're like
um slogan to win was if you want a for a
neighbor vote labor
okay so this is what we had to deal with
and then it was all legal on this [ __ ]
yes so we had like our roof yeah we've
got a spot on got a cup with this one
where are you where are you based here
Hitchin Hertfordshire right yeah
um that's where my dad came in the
family he moved in we had to live with
our uncles
um there's about 11 of us in one house
wow yeah because uh we can't afford
anything yet but this is when the
government wanted people to come in
from India to work so my dad and my mom
came over
and but all we got was [ __ ] man so was
there a sense that you'd been kind of
brought here and welcomed here by the
government but when you got here it was
a different situation to what had been
so that's what my dad thought yeah
because they just wandered out of India
at the end they they thought
um you hear stories in India people
going on about it the streets are paver
gold blah blah blah no they're not it's
a [ __ ] nightmare Friday
it's a nightmare yeah so they all come
running over here because they want to
escape that one
um but once they get here it's a
difficult story right
um and did you were you born here or
were you brought up born here born here
so even born here you immediately
experienced the difference and uh yeah
yes yes yes
um I couldn't speak English until I was
three uh in my house we always spoke
Punjabi uh because that's my mum and dad
that was a native tongue and I didn't
mix with nobody I wasn't allowed mixing
nobody
and a stutter I had disabilities I was
like uh backward a little bit you know
um what do you mean by backward yeah
because I wasn't because
I had like it was like quite hard work
for me man you know you know were you at
school and that kind of thing no Nursery
I didn't go the first time I went to
school they just they just got me back
in the house my mom and dad uh used to
put us in child care minders and that
house got
read it by the police
the first time I was in the cells I was
three years old
because these were illegal
child minders and they were like taking
on loads of kids and my mom and dad used
to like
drop me or my sister off at this house
and there was like a mixture of children
there yeah okay all colors every [ __ ]
Nation there blah blah blah don't know
who these people were but my mom doesn't
have to go to work so they used to look
after us but they were illegal
they got rid of the police
uh the police of the red that locked us
all up in the bathroom upstairs the
police brought the door down I was only
three years old my sister was two and
then there's all talks to sells until
our mum and dads come to pick us up do
you remember this or is it something
you've been told about afterwards no no
I remember no I remember the first time
I got arrested and that police read
um we got locked in the bathroom and
then we all got put in ourselves
um
because that's how it worked back in the
day they just put us all in sells kids
themselves yeah three years old yes yes
yes yes yes yes yes yes that happened I
mean it's it's it's kind of a bad setup
for your relationship with the law that
isn't it yeah in terms of like if you
have one of your first members yes yes
yes a three and I hear them initially
and when you talk about things about
getting spat on in the street and stuff
like that I mean is that was that just
out and out racism just people seeing
you yes yeah
skinned were the norm the big boot uh
the braces
blah blah blah they used to walk around
in town bashing was the norm it wasn't
even illegal
it wasn't even illegal
you couldn't even if if you got [ __ ]
up if you were Batman
of the police the police would say okay
that's that's normal right so yeah it's
normal even at that age as a I guess at
this age when you're getting attacked it
must have been teenage years or
something no I was only [ __ ] six
seven on that but my Mom and Dad they
they were good they were [ __ ] on it
yeah getting a [ __ ]
um
and I felt all that and it was in 1984
we moved up to Newcastle yeah to uh try
and get a better life and I was in a
shop there and we were the first brown
people to move up to that area
and that was a scary experience
being the first ones in there yeah the
first ones there because there was like
um I was on the till blah blah blah and
the kid will say ma what's that and
she'll say it's a Jesus Christ and
you'll see I've never seen one of them
before because we were the first ones
there and they all used to laugh in the
queue
those who laugh and money I used to put
out put the money in my hand throw it on
the front counter because it's uh
because we're Brown
so they didn't want to like touch hands
they don't want to touch me man
so from an early age it sounds like you
were kind of
siled off a bit it's like yes I heard it
I heard it I heared everything
Newcastle
a star I had
um bullied in school yes I got all the
way through it when I got out of that
more of it
had enough man and I wanna react I react
did you have friends at that point no no
no family members of similar age
anything like that none uh brother
sister
um
Brothers he moved out he moved out when
the uni blah blah blah five years older
than me he didn't want any part of this
[ __ ] uh because he was gay right and
back then
to be gay and to be sick is like oh God
big No-No yeah okay you are like
condemned condemned and oh so did he
just say goodbye to the whole and went
to Manchester United yeah and did his
own thing which is fair enough which is
fair enough I don't blame for that
uh my sister a year younger
she came up afterwards and I took care
of them but we all just took [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] okay so you got to this point where
you were like I've had enough of taking
[ __ ] and you started to push back yeah
what point is it then you start
interacting with Society like what's
your first job as a kind of like first
job I was just in the shop as a shop
yeah my dad had a shop there
um so I was just like
staff member and I work for free I used
to come home from school wasn't allowed
to to go out wasn't allowed to do this
when I'll do that I had to go back start
the shelves and go on a till while my
old man went on the piss now do you
still see your siblings and your family
are you still close with them my mum my
mum my dad cool my brother my sister
yeah we're all right ish
ish uh
because they never back me up yet and
they're not really happy with what I've
done in the end but really I'm not happy
what what they've done either
because I had to back them up you know
I'm the one that took the [ __ ] so the
one that takes a [ __ ] uh you you hate
him for it why because I'm the one
that's stuck there I'm the one who
stared there I'm the one that got
spawned not them because they run off so
obviously what you're known for what
we've known you for is quite high
profile
criminal activity yeah yep yep yeah what
what you're talking to me about here is
basically a guy that moved to an area
got treated pretty
terribly
what's the point where you started to
dabble in this kind of you know you're
at the point you're talking about now
you're working in the family business at
what point did you start moving across
into world life okay
the point our moves was like I knew
where we at yeah we were just getting
[ __ ] in the shop shitty [ __ ]
customers or racist I thought [ __ ]
this is not for me yeah I'll [ __ ] this
[ __ ] off
um I want to [ __ ] make some moves
there I want to make some moves so I
opened up a close-up
a close shop in Newcastle High fashion
but I had to close that down because the
shop was was not making money so I was
working with Gangster firms from the
Northeast credit card fraud okay
um what you were doing credit card bag
snatching yeah they were like okay
snatching bags blah blah blah coming in
with fresh cards check coming through
your shop and I will go yes gone and
because we've got one to two hours
before it's recorded through
and then back then it was just like uh
you know oh the machine yeah
and that was easy to do we could wreck a
card for thousands and how old were you
here
23 23. sorry through 24. and that was
back when did you say that was 90s 90s
yeah so I guess to a young guy who'd
come from an unpaid family business
uh-huh that must have been a lot of
money do you think that's what gave you
a bit of a taste for the operating
outside the system
well give me a test was I want to hide
baby I wanted to [ __ ] I want to make
Mills not the [ __ ] eating liquid
right shut the [ __ ] about Andrew quit
yeah all of my meals yeah so I'm saying
I'm gonna sell drugs right so yeah with
that you were looking and going how do I
make the big money and I knew after this
I have to sell drugs
because in the 90s it's so easy to do it
how does a youngish guy in Newcastle at
that point in time how do you get into
selling how do I get into that right
steroids dorm when I was a domino for
that yeah okay because I was training I
was that big
I knew a few guys I said listen the shop
had to close down we had to close the
shop down and he says right
but my mum and dad's shop was already
operating anywhere so I was working
there already saw the income anyway
second income I wanted Dorman but then I
wanted a third income selling drugs so I
wanted like three or four incomes coming
in not just one so at this point you've
moved into door work and then you said
it's steroids is that right you were
saying steroids I was selling at first
yeah so where do you how do you find
these steroids to sell like right how do
I find them um and I knew a guy I was
working with in Newcastle
he used to get them I used to buy off
him okay markup was like fine blah blah
blah but then I thought no listen I
should be the one bringing this [ __ ]
bringing it in I should be I want to be
the main man not him I I don't want to
go to him to buy yeah people should be
buying off me so I made the moves in
Pakistan was the uh cheapest place in
the [ __ ] world to buy
because nobody wants to work Pakistan
man Al-Qaeda Taliban blah blah blah oh
so at that point in time was that quite
oh heavy yeah heavy it's always been
heavy it's heavy now I mean was that not
an intimidating thing for you no no I
loved it I love the [ __ ] I loved it man
what the the danger oh yeah I loved it I
love my [ __ ] all right let's go and die
we either [ __ ] do it all we die yeah
because my life has been ships tonight
yeah so I couldn't even [ __ ] and
I said are you [ __ ] make it
or I'm gonna [ __ ] go to jail or boom
shot so talk us through the first trip
who are you going with here you go right
uh second
cousins I went with we didn't know where
where to start or what to do or where to
go uh we just landed but I said listen I
know what I'll do yeah I know what to do
so
um why what did you say that because you
wanted to be in control or were you just
kind of yeah no I want to be in control
I'm the boss man but did you think you
knew what to do why were you just going
out no I knew I would do it right I knew
I would do it I knew I would do this I
know I could go to Pakistan Pakistan
corrupt the [ __ ]
um like all them other countries I know
I can pay people off there I can buy
people off I can buy the police the
airport security I know I can do this so
I went yes I'm gonna do it so I changed
my name to Jack Khan
Muslim name just so I don't get
kidnapped or shot in Pakistan because if
they think I'm a Sikh because India and
Pakistan uh aren't too good with each
other especially when I'm going to buy
drugs yeah
so it's a No-No Jack Khan but I was a
nice guy to them and I paid and I paid
my way and I did my dues and they were
cool me well let's go let's go through
it step by step because obviously if
someone like me or potentially I'd
imagine a lot of our listeners it's a
completely different world to what we're
used to so you land in Pakistan yeah
take us through it we like went around
first we had a company name from a box
we traveled to that company
which was two hours drive Pakistan
spoke to the manager I said listen what
kind of company sorry
uh
steroid company got you so you're going
to go to them and say come on
yeah we went to the original company I
said listen I want to buy a few when are
you a pharmaceutical company I went no
uh we just want to buy a lot of you yeah
he went no and what do you mean no I
went listen repair you what you want
yeah
and you just went nah
it was it like I was really shocked by
this yeah because I thought I could buy
anybody off in Pakistan and that's a
two-hour drive out the window and this
is a two hour drive out the window and
then we were all a bit [ __ ] up so we
went about the hotel
prostitutes I spoke to they went listen
talk to these people talk to this person
talk to that person no we went we made
some contacts traded this little caller
I don't know their original name but uh
they had a
set up in a market store yeah is that a
market stall but they had every pill for
sale rough Nepal Valium any everything
illegal here is available there and he
said I can supply you because everybody
else said
they could all you have give us 10 of
these 10 of them I would no we want a
hundred thousand Jesus yeah they were no
we we can't
because these guys are doing it so
they're linked us up with these guys
they went there the man supplies and
when we went he was uh Sons were there
with shotguns this is a market store
shotguns at the market shotgun to the
market store and the only chemist it's a
chemist
it's a chemist shotgun's here outside
because people try and Rob it oh yeah
okay because there's big money coming
through and we landed with 30 large
and we had to pay for the stock up front
he said listen I can supply you
everything you want
all right you're not intimidated at this
point I wasn't but my cousins were
I mean you're walking in somewhere you
don't know they're standing out the
front with shotguns yeah understand in
Pakistan you know that there's a problem
we're handing over 30 grand yeah yeah
they don't they they could have told me
to [ __ ] off yeah I mean I'm getting
nothing what can I do about that get a
shot but you know what they did that
they did the work
the supply they said listen I'm back
here back here back here and he's not
see talk us through you go in there the
guy's sitting there yeah is he not
suspicious of you no because he's a big
time drug dealer so he feels safe yeah
because as soon as there were shotguns
again right and you said there's three
of you going there yes you say what you
want uh
we see the order
can you get this can you get that he
says yes he went have a look on my shelf
and you just had a little stall you know
it was only about the size of but I
don't know smallish but he says I can
supply you with anything you want
anything you want heroin even
1
500 for a kilo and that's 90 Proof and
back here you sell that for 50 large
wow yeah
okay so you can bash that up twice so
you can make a hundred of that so you
pay 1 500 and you can make a hundred and
you're trying to buy steroids is that
right steroid only so interesting heroin
nuts so you're giving the money up front
yeah when do you come back to get your
the next day the next day next day all
packed up two taxis we have to get for
all the stock but how much have you
bought at this point how many 30 Grands
worth uh it was like a hundred thousand
ambuls volume then I just took a little
back then but then the markup on the
Blues
volume was massive I was buying a
thousand
tablets there for nine pound
street value here a thousand
it's a counter pill wow nine pound for a
thousand pills so you can so you can
work out the money I was making
especially if you're spending 30 grand
30 grand theft yeah all right so you've
got you come back the next day you've
got the taxis you take them to the
airport no hotel Back to the Hotel no
they have to get packed up right they
have to get packed up
um
my taxi driver first the first job he
did
well I did yeah porno mugs I gave my
porno mugs right okay you can't get them
in Pakistan okay illegal right they have
never seen a white girl naked okay so
when you show them a magazines are like
oh my God they're like [ __ ] on what
the [ __ ] right I'm like okay I can give
this magazine if you do work for me so
this is how you get work done over there
how did you have a how did you have the
problem because we're gonna paste that
Mom we gotta walk for [ __ ] a week
all right okay okay all right so you so
you did you know it was illegal to take
it in no no it's an eagle so you got
there with you buy at the airport can't
you uh Newcastle airport
all right all right all right
so you get to you get to um you get you
get to the taxi driver you give him the
porno mag yeah and you and what do you
say to him we need these well I said to
him I said listen
I said I'll pay you right I said I'll
pay you as well
um I was gonna pay my month's wage to
get the boxes packed
he said right I'll do it and what he did
was this he took it back to his [ __ ]
village where where he was at yeah he
got all the young boys to come sat them
all down in front of him and said right
listen
there was like
um one ampule in each box right okay but
these all have to be packed down six in
each box okay and there's like a hundred
thousand abules here yeah okay so it's
gonna it's gonna take a long time yeah
so he went right what he did he got all
the boys you met this is what we want
packed everything has to be packed down
like boom it's massive at the minute but
it has to be condensed small so they can
take it across
so what you did show them the first page
of the porno magazine right the boys
right
do one box and I'll turn the page over
oh my God yes so you got it done for
free
all these young kids just bro they were
just packing it and he was just showing
them just showing my page and I paid
them A month's wages my God so you've
landed in Pakistan and basically
corrupted an entire Village yeah
please enjoy your first visit right
okay so you get that lot to the airport
it's all packed up now
you got them in suitcases is that right
yes and how I mean this is a point where
if I was doing something like this I'd
be extremely nervous I'm assuming based
on the conversation we've had so far you
weren't no you don't seem to be someone
who feeds us that kind of I knew I could
do it I knew I could do it
and what about your cousins
they were a bit unsure but I had the
confidence okay so you get to customs
yeah talk us through it firstly they
weren't openly cases there's like six of
them there boom open them up we're all
biggish and we won't listen personal use
this is laughter yeah because the case
was just [ __ ] full of gear doing that
it's not personal use
and then the Singapore magazines on the
side of your suitcase
I won't you you want it
anyway yeah go on then I will listen
I've got two for you
take them two and let us go through and
then right here
this is airport security
Pakistan yeah if you imagine this now
right and then the other x-ray machine
and then we have to go through another
x-ray machine the same thing happened
then I bottom off again with two more
mugs my cousin will go [ __ ] old [ __ ]
yeah you're [ __ ] so no money no money
no money just the magazines and the next
time I went through the new who I was
and then and then they started wanting
money off me but that first time it was
just the first time poor magazine wow I
mean they were quite the investment
weren't they to them I bet they still
have them now right because it's
impossible to get it it's impossible to
get impact is done okay all right so
then you get them on the plane and then
are you flying straight back to the UK
Amsterdam Amsterdam change your
Amsterdam Amsterdam to Newcastle at this
point you must be feeling because you're
not going to be paying off I know yeah
yeah yeah we were stressed out a little
bit we had been drinking so bring up now
a little bit uh the flight was early in
the morning
we were like deep breaths right let's
see what goes down and Newcastle is this
in Newcastle yeah Customs weren't there
we just walked straight through boom
high fives
because it was a morning shift as
morning shift and it's come from
Amsterdam because
um
the flight because the Pakistan tags
took them off
yeah because if I know you're coming
from Pakistan they will have a look at
your bags but we took them tags off and
just left Amsterdam tags on so it just
looks as the room okay okay and you just
walk straight through into Newcastle
you've got it all yeah
how long till you went again
six weeks God because I roll that money
over boom that was sold straight away
let's go back let's go back so I went
back again I fell on my cousins and then
I started to take mules over so at that
point you're in that's our team that's
your life yeah and can you explain for
anyone that doesn't know what a mule is
a mule is somebody that carries drugs I
paid them a thousand pound and I'll pay
the flight all expenses or food blah
blah blah everything paid for and you
get a grand in your pocket but these
people don't work
benefits they're on blob you know
they've got nothing to do anyway they've
never been outside [ __ ] England and
uh so if I'm giving them a grant to
carry a case back and I've told them
coming back England Class C it's uh
maximum jail here then was
two years I went first time you get
caught you you're gonna get a full call
anyway but Spain is classy
I didn't realize this oh God so okay
well we'll get we'll get on to that but
so with the mules essentially the
payment is for them to take the risk for
you is that what it is yeah so you pay
them a grand and the flight and all that
but that's on the understanding that if
they get caught they go to prison they
say it was them
yes right and with that how like were
they people you knew or how do you find
yes well there's loads that the Lords
are saying to me I want to go I want to
go right okay so you've started running
repeated trips
how long was it until you got caught the
first time right I did it for a couple
yeah yeah
I can't say how many trips I've done
obviously yeah and I don't want people
who uh I don't want the feds to work it
all out what is me and I suppose you
can't say how much money you had double
figures double figures man yeah double
figures I did for the trips yeah and for
the amount of money that you had yes it
was like uh
I was making about 60 Grand a trip
it's a lot of money back here back in
the 90s it was silly money
but not the cash boxes I had 20 pound
notes I had yeah cash boxes safety
in Banks right back then you could just
get a box and now you now you can't now
they want to know everything yeah okay
but back then you could the 20 pound
note I had to get changed into 50 pound
notes because there was no space in the
boxes right
God and it still wasn't enough for them
but you weren't you weren't like okay
that's enough now I'll just live off
that yeah
okay rolling I'm rolling it rolling
until I get [ __ ] done okay yeah and
it is the time it's the first time you
get caught is that the big one in Spain
oh did you get caught before that no
that was the first one for drugs okay
that's the big one all right so talk us
through how you got to that point I went
through Spain because I lost the load I
lost the load
um because right we changed it Amsterdam
but our bags never came through two
mules ahead of me
uh the bags never came through and then
they said right your bags are on the
next flight and oh [ __ ]
but the mules were happy about this
because they're because they're still
paid the grand another phone case right
so [ __ ] them yeah so I'll [ __ ] you
anyway Newcastle airport said right your
bags are here and we've opened them up
but we will tell you if you come to
collect these bags you are going to get
arrested
they called you and said that yeah
that's a strange thing to do I know it's
because classy I know because they open
my bags but it's strange for them to
warn you I would have said well the
warping bags this is England any other
country they wouldn't even tell you you
just turn up and be arrested yeah but
England has said uh this is law we have
open your bags and we and we will say to
you if you do come and get these you are
you are going to be arrested so I guess
you didn't go no so I thought [ __ ] that
I've saw a different route I take
through Spain
through Spain and then I was going to
get the channel
tunnel back and what you didn't realize
was that the class C Drugs in the UK
were classified in Spain yeah
let's talk about
how you got caught you why were you
there why instead of the mules you know
like what was the point you realized you
were caught let's go into that in Spain
Interpol flight
um interpol on my case
um
tracked all my flights they knew what I
was doing the chief narcotics officer
karachiopa he said
I will guarantee you safe boom out of
here
but once you're out of here
it's got nothing to do with me yeah okay
so all right fair enough and um
but people were knowing my operation
obviously and there must have been
knowing I meant a lot of money I'm doing
this I'm doing that and the person
taught the police blah blah blah
tracking me and
Interpol knew I was doing that when I
landed in Spain for the first time there
was there were guns boom
City London yeah
that must have been quite a yeah feeling
yes so what's the process do they grab
you straight away or do they make you
open the bags or how does it work well
yeah
the bags our bags were lit everybody
else has their bags
I was
not there
so wait we're waiting
waiting because the police Interpol had
to come so embryos had left the airport
at this point and where I just [ __ ]
stood there waiting waiting for our bags
but really the police are going to come
the guardian Seville boom Interpol and
doing it right you bam we know what
you're doing on this laughter whoa look
around this
and
it was like for them it was a good bust
um
there's a good bust and did you say to
me at the beginning it was the biggest
one they'd ever had at that point and
yes it's the biggest pharmaceutical bust
in Spanish history and still is
a quarter of a million pills and 50 000
amules and that's just you yeah right
okay so
what happens next
we got locked up man
um the mules the the police were
interrogating them
and
they did say okay it's him it's all him
because they were scaring him they said
you're gonna get 10 to 15 yeah yeah
right so you either say who's who is the
boss
they knew I was a boss anyway and um but
they didn't want to hear of them and
once I heard it of them cushion number
they got they got a nice cells this and
that I got put in a
container outside with no windows and no
food or water for two days wow two days
pissing the [ __ ] corner and [ __ ]
really yeah yeah
did you know at that point you were in
prison I'm [ __ ] yeah because they took
everything off me I rings I had jewelry
the police Spanish police just took
anything off me they went we know who
you are and those took my rings my watch
my this my life everything everything's
zero boom left for [ __ ] all Container
outside
do you ever see that stuff again no no
never that was just gone gone okay so
you're outside in the container at this
point scared or no yes yeah yeah
because I know what's coming here but uh
bill I was told I would get bail
so if you get a good lawyer blah blah
blah but um that never happened either
that never happened
so after that is it straight to court
for you
two and a half years on the site first
before I won the court so it's straight
to prison straight a prison because they
want to do research on me see if I've
got a yacht in Spain I've got any houses
got cars because they wanted to take
everything off me right they want to
take everything off me so they stopped
me uh
doing their [ __ ] things whatever they
[ __ ] do I don't know what the feds
[ __ ] do but they didn't find focal
anyway and um I had nothing in Spain
anyway but two and a half years of
talking to that and you've spoken before
about I think it was quite a violent
prison wasn't it yeah so you get to
prison in Spain obviously I don't think
you spoke Spanish did you with that no
no so you get to a Spanish prison which
is quite a sort of high security violent
prison how did you get on when you got
in there
not good at first not good I was angry
um on a
come down I'd lost [ __ ] the FED to
talk about 100 Grand of me I I had lost
a lot of money
um it was hard work man
um
and where I was at I was
Katie
um the Spanish deals funkalenta is the
worst jail in Spain and Spanish jails
are the worst in
Europe and I'm in the worst wing
so I'm in the worst place you can be I
think with and everybody there was in
for like massive sentences a third of my
AIDS they're all murderers killers and
but they stuck me there because I
thought I had I had money
and they thought I was a high risk
and it was and it wasn't [ __ ] easy
man
um
I thought I was I was gonna get a bail
for the first month I thought I was
gonna get Bill Bill and then after about
a month
sunken right I'm here for a long haul
10 years
and 10 years 10 years that that's what I
got told you
and I thought I can't do 10 years with
all these people because they've all got
AIDS stabbing each other dearly they're
on smack I was on heroin
just to escape a little bit or you were
buying that in the jail because the jail
that you're in I think Funk collent is
there's a famous story that one of the
prisoners once got stabbed for snoring
in that prison is it like is that what
you decide you saw of it like the high
level yeah yeah it's terrible man
terrible you can stop there for [ __ ] all
yeah you're gonna stop for [ __ ] off if
you look at somebody the wrong way you
can get a [ __ ] knife stuck in your
neck so were you trying to sort of find
allies in there or were you just staying
off on your on your own right at first I
was staying off my own sort of thing
um as there was only a couple of people
who could speak English
there was a Algerian guy he could he
could speak English so I stuck with him
and he told me how it rolls Carlos he
was there he could speak English he he
was educated by all the rest English not
so I had to learn the language and the
screws refused to speak to you in
English
even though they know English
they were safe hablas espanol
which means speak Spanish right yeah
um so because you're here now you're not
English so not [ __ ] trying to speak
English with us did you feel threatened
while you're in there was there a
constant sense of danger from other
person yes yes yeah the other the other
night
um
they're on therefore
stabbings and [ __ ] Petty [ __ ]
arguments over [ __ ] drugs um this is
their life because they're all doing 34
years they've got AIDS they know they're
they're not leaving they ain't leaving
that place they know they're gonna die
there so they will take anybody out
so that there's no sense of getting out
for them and that's they're in the worst
yes they can be anywhere yes yeah and
that's what I thought I was in
so did you have any altercations with
people or were you staying off no Lord
Lord I had loads of fights there ask
that people there did you I got stabbed
there twice God I'm gonna stop twice and
I'll stop people there based on just
arguments [ __ ] yeah the first time I
stabbed somebody
right what happened
you get pills yeah every day
um they give you pills to like keep
everybody calm because this is like
dangerous people here so they pill you
up here so everyone's on a [ __ ] lower
level this guy he got his pills Juan and
he
tax people so he would take pills off
people Bam Bam Bam and he took of this
little guy and he was sat on the [ __ ]
step crying and when um
Carlos I was with and then and and then
I couldn't even
speak their language and I said look
Carl
ask him yeah what what what's wrong with
him and he said okay Juan tax me am I
has he I mean who you want him over
there all right okay so I'll walk over
to him yeah now at this point yeah I'm
I'm right you know me I'm [ __ ] angry
as [ __ ] here because I'm here I'm stuck
here so I thought okay I'm stuck here
I'm gonna [ __ ] I'm gonna kill it as
well [ __ ] them all
why did you take this pills he went
[ __ ] and do what the [ __ ] I want yeah
what the [ __ ] I gotta do with you but
this is throwing the temperature Carlos
right he was speaking Spanish and Carlos
was telling me what he was saying in
Spanish in English so this is through
interpreter an argument all right yeah
really I went tell him showers now fight
amen totally me all right okay look
let's [ __ ] all right go on then so
showers we went
I thought it's a fist fight yeah
um but the interpretation must have got
a bit mixed up and it was a knife fight
Jesus yeah Knife Fight right I didn't
even [ __ ] know this so I walked in
the showers
and then he pulls out a [ __ ] blade on
me yeah and I'm all right okay baby and
then Carlo he goes here have mine and
then you just handed me the blade
um he took a swipe at me bam Miss bam I
stuck him
put him on his ass uh it went straight
through them and straight through the
middle of them and um
he got to a hospital but he didn't open
his mouth
I don't know what happened to him
uh but his cousin six months later
stabbed me in the back
in the gym with with like a nail on the
shank Jesus Christ So when you say you
don't know what happened to him do you
know that if he lived or died or oh
don't care no
do you ever think about stuff like that
no no no [ __ ] him he wanted to kill me
right
and all that came from the guy that had
been taxed did you know that guy no that
was an innocent so why were you so angry
about him I don't know I'm just angry
man I was just sitting there [ __ ] I
just [ __ ] hate [ __ ] like that people
getting picked on bullied does he remind
you of when you were a kid yeah
um
yeah
interesting so I thought if I can stick
up I'll [ __ ] will stick up I'll be
honest that sounds horrific to me did
you ever say anything like that did you
ever see anything else in prison going
on like that did you see worse things
than that yeah
Carlo another guy
he was the man is this the guy that your
parents with no a different color
another Carlo this Carlo was doing uh
life double life uh he killed two people
inside Julie went in initially for
burglary but once he was inside he
started to [ __ ] inject got AIDS and
then mindset wrong and then you start
people and then he killed another two
people so he was on that Wing but he was
like
seven stones skinny but his eyes were
dead you could see he was [ __ ] in the
head yeah but his family had money and
he was a man smack
dealer on the wing
so his story was this
um this other guy what happens here in
Spain everybody graspses everybody up
right but this is a wrong person to
Grass up and he didn't really know this
one because he come from a different
Wing had a fight come an hour Wing he
knew he was a heroine dealer glassed him
up the screws the screws grass collower
Carlo up yes
um Carlo got searched Bam Bam Bam did 30
days down the block down the hall is
that solitary yes that's the whole oh
it's tiny the space and you don't get to
see anybody for a whole [ __ ] month
the food gets just pushed under through
the floor and I must be intense you're
not even allowed to walk outside or even
talk to anybody 30 days he did there 30
days he came out
the people thing right Carlo okay I made
a move in him yeah he's already killed
two people inside already
the man move
Saturdays visit comes right family
members come it's like um glass window
got the phone there on the other side
usloc we get filed in this side cubicles
boom boom boom
other people are on your side obviously
yeah and um Carlo had a visit and this
guy grasped him how to visit
of his mom is niece
and
sister came to see him three women
anyway Carlo shank up his ass here
because we all get a metal detector here
okay but if it's up your ass it does not
do it because it doesn't go through skin
and uh so yeah
so he put it up his ass went into the
cubicles
he went to his cubicle Carlo went to his
and then took the shank up with us
walked into his cubicle and stabbed him
11 times in front of his mama killed him
there and then and then he came behind
the wind and went
why didn't you do that earlier he went
no I want to kill him in front of his
mom he said I want to make a [ __ ]
example of the [ __ ] you don't
grasp God you've said a few times about
them having AIDS what's the what's that
why do people have Aid in there
sharing needles mostly I see sharing
needles rape happens yes but catching is
that that is what is like
rare because if you [ __ ] somebody with
AIDS if you've got age if somebody else
there's only one in 60 chance you can
get it so it's quite slight but you said
at that point you were taking heroin
were you not worried about that using I
was smoking man okay I never injected
right because of that I well yes I don't
share my needle yeah I mean it sounds
like a disturbing experience how long
how long we've been there for three
years
three years so so you'd had your how
long were you sentenced for two and a
half years ago two and a half years
until I got a sentence and then I had to
and then and then I learned Spanish I
spoke to the top heads there the bank
robbers this that and listen you need
this lawyer because this lawyer he knows
corrupt people pay them off he went okay
he's gonna want money off you but he'll
get your sentence halved all right
Willie I'm all right okay four and a
half year ago in the end because he'd
spoken to this respond to them and I
paid them nine grand nine grand nine and
a half years yeah I mean that's that's
worth it isn't it oh yes
yeah well I mean yeah I mean but I know
but they do this daily right this
happens on a daily basis so
if you're getting Grands Grands grunts
have done a daily basis so you're you're
you've done
three and a half years he gets sentenced
to four and a half so you've got like a
year left to do at that point no I'd
two and a half I did he's done two and a
half two and a half four and a half I
got so I only have to save three six
months I had left piece of cake man so
at that point you were just like I'm
going home I'm going home soon baby yeah
but surely at that point the fear of
things happening in prison must have
lifted because if you get if you end up
uh getting in a altercation with someone
and something happens to them you might
get added yes yes yes yes this is why I
was scared this why I got stabbed in the
back when he stabbed me
I turned around yeah it just felt like a
thud okay just it's fast and I turn
around fine I just banged him
and then I felt and then and then I felt
it yeah and then I seen this [ __ ]
knife and then I was thinking do I take
a knife was sticking his [ __ ] neck
but I'm thinking if I do that I'm I'm
getting a tenure here baby
so I had to leave it I left it
to get out so get on man
so you get um
the days approaching to the day are
leaving
did you know what your end date was or
was it no no my lawyer was was that cool
he got the expulsion
I got expulsion I got out two months
earlier
expelled so I can't enter so they gave
me a condition I can't enter spin for 10
years
I said okay I'm happy with that I don't
want to come [ __ ] back here anyway
yeah
so and we're gonna expel you okay you
can't come back for
10 years all right
the screw head screw he went sandup I
don't know what I was in a gym at a time
training he went papers of hair you're
out what
and what now he went go pack his stuff
but I was that happy I just had shorts
on the vest on I was that happy that I
was going I just gave all my clothes and
all my [ __ ] away to everybody so I went
to the airport and just my shorts and my
vest November
I got weak I also got flying backwards
just sitting how you left two Marshals
two Marshalls handcuffed I was
handcuffed at the Battle of flight 12
seats they had to like uh people had to
move and they held back the flight gun
Marshalls handcuffed Gatwick they
checked if I need if I had any offenses
here there were no you have not
open the cuffs and we're right [ __ ] off
they just walked you in okay shots and a
vest yeah cool what time is this
it was about seven o'clock in the
evening and then I didn't even get a
hotel because I was that like excited to
be out I just walked around London all
night all day I just like walked because
I've never seen
people like normal people for three
[ __ ] years hashisha had up my ass you
learned a lot imprisonment
your ass there is an extra
pocket okay yeah that's where you keep
everything
um so some cash I had because I used to
be the the money lender in jail
that was my job in jail money lending
um getting double back the next [ __ ]
week blah blah blah that's how I made
the money there so I thought if I could
make money here I could make money
anywhere basically I know there's lots
of other things that have happened in
your life after that this is the main
the main bit I want to talk about we did
a previous video together there was
quite a lot of comments on that but I
don't know if you looked at any of them
right it was interesting going through
them because it kind of like it fell
into a split of
half the people were like saying stuff
like all I see is a guy that had a bad
start in life and tried to make the best
of it and the other half was saying this
guy doesn't care about anyone yeah which
side do you fall on do you see yourself
as someone that had a bad start and then
had to fight to get anywhere in life yes
I did yes it was yes it was it was a
struggle man and if I didn't do what I
did where would it be
still being a [ __ ] until
in the shop no no I want to do it man I
want to do it I want to admit the
millions I want the fuckiness I want
this I want that I want to do this
control areas I wanna Empire
and how do you feel now do you still
feel that way or have you calm down oh I
still feel a [ __ ] way
I am Karma I am Karma but Zero Tolerance
I have with people if somebody even like
no I'm like jail mode is set in my head
like in jail somebody looks at you the
wrong way
you act on it um
you act on it and do you think that time
that you spent in the Spanish prison is
do you think it's affected you for the
rest of your life yes
when you look back on that you know you
went from like you say working in a
family business to having
um the biggest
drugs in part that they'd had on their
history their records at that point
it's a lot of your life that you went to
prison for in Spain yeah and other
places yeah do you have any regrets
regret yes because because I lost my
children you know I wasn't a dad
I had four kids and I was [ __ ] it all
up yeah because I was just concentrating
on dollar dollar on drugs and
[ __ ] up I [ __ ] up there yes I did yes
I did and now
they don't like the person I am
they don't which is understandable
because I wasn't there from it
but at the time
the drugs and the money and the [ __ ]
what I wanted
overpowered
being a dad can me
being a dad was like secondary
is that something you'd like to work on
further well I tried to I try to get
them back I'd probably be cool
but uh then having it
been having it
And when they see you on things like
this because you've done quite a lot of
yeah kind of stuff like this do you
think they watch it do they I don't know
yes they do probably watch it but I
don't know they never give me a comment
on it they never tell me but um they're
not happy with me man one thing that was
there was a lot of comments about on the
first video is at the end when you're
talking about the impact your life had
had on your family you got quite
emotional and a lot of people said in
that that like because you come across
as I mean even to me who've met you a
few times you're quite an intimidating
bloke you know you're obviously somebody
who has you don't have a lot of fear
within you you're very driven about
getting what you want and it's
potentially it doesn't matter who's
standing in your way oh [ __ ] well a lot
of the comments on that first video were
saying like essentially there's there's
ones that say but you can see that he is
a good guy because he gots emotional
about the impact it had in his family I
just what do you think about that
yeah my mom man
[ __ ] her up did I get a relationship
my children yeah
uh I wasn't really thinking about that
at the time you know at the time I was
just thinking about the drugs the money
the [ __ ] Fame this that who I am
uh
20s or then yeah that was like boom
powering me through it
uh
but yeah my mum
my mom
I'll do it again you wouldn't do it
again I did two sentences yeah the first
sentence killed her when I went in again
wow Kill The Reef more of
and is that the the impact it had on her
is what would stop you yep reliving that
life again
yeah
oh well no yeah
it's really interesting meeting you
checks obviously you have a totally
different life to wearing anything I've
ever known
and what occurs to me is that you had
like a pretty [ __ ] start and you did
what you thought you had to do to get
yourself through
and
obviously you made those decisions then
and uh it is sad to see that the impact
it's had on you because a lot of it I
think probably wasn't at the very
beginning you got set up badly
but look
do you want a minute
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh do you want
a bit about seven up get a bit of a
sugar rush off it
foreign
[Music]
and we went down to the bottom and a
vehicle reversed in a tank a warrior
reversed in the back doors opened and we
all piled in the back
and that was it the vehicle just stayed
there I'm chugging on the Commander's
leg or we need to go now and it turned
out the driver had been hit in the head